con desinfectante en la puerta así son
recibidos los alumnos esa es la nueva
normalidad en el regreso a clases de los
niños franceses en marsella una clase
tuvo bienvenida a presidencia que quiere
ser cuando seas grande un presidente
quiero ser presidente o vendedor de
automóviles para una nueva compañía
bueno esas dos cosas no tienen nada en
común te gustan los carros y pero los
doctores están preocupados la tasa de
infección entre los niños es superior a
la del año pasado por estas fechas y
alrededor del 37% de los adolescentes en
francia todavía no están vacunados la
pandemia va a empeorar otra vez en
francia siempre que nos sigamos
reuniendo todavía hay 9 millones 400.000
niños menores de 12 años que no están
vacunados y 9.300.000 adultos o personas
mayores de los 12 años que no están
vacunadas todos los niños mayores de 6
años tienen que usar una máscara adentro
sin estudiante de primaria o
bachillerato entra en contacto con un
caso de kobe los miembros de su clase
que están vacunados no tendrán que
aislarse pero para los estudiantes más
jóvenes la clase entera tendrá que tener
un tiempo fuera los maestros están
haciendo su mejor esfuerzo para evitar
contagios
además hay máscaras disponibles para
estudiantes y visitantes el
antibacterial en todos los salones de
clases y áreas comunes purificadores de
aire sensores de co2 en los salones
protocolos barreras de plástico en el
comedor limitando el contacto de
diferentes grados limitación de masas o
colectivo para ayudar a mantener la baja
propagación del virus el ministro de
educación ha anunciado un plan de seis
mil test de saliva a la semana en los
colegios de toda francia